en 2014 écrivain blogueur saoudien reich
badaoui a écopé d'une peine de prison de
10 en 2000 coups de fouet assorti d'une
lourde amende
son crime avoir publié un blog free
saoudi liberals libérer les libéraux
saoudien lee militer pour un allègement
des contraintes religieuses et inciter
les internautes à contribuer au débat
ses écrits lui ont valu une fatwa un
emprisonnement à partir de 2012 un
procès accusé d' apostasie d' insulte à
l'islam de désobéissance à son père il a
été lourdement condamné il a reçu dès le
9 janvier 2015 à djeddah en public 50
coups de bâton cette séance de torture à
ciel ouvert a été condamné par les
autorités du monde entier et dénoncées
par l'onu
et pourtant dès son arrivée au pouvoir
le prince mohammed bin salman a fait
connaître ses velléités de libéraliser
le royaume son plan vision 2030 laissa
entrevoir un futur plus désirable
notamment pour les femmes saoudiennes
permis de conduire incitations à
travailler fin de la soumission un
tuteur une femme pourra donc vivre seul
voilà pour les avancés
reste que dans le royaume l'idéologie
wahhabite est toujours dominante
mohamed ben salman dans un discours en
avril dernier a pourtant appelés à ne
pas s'enfermer dans une école de pensée
religieuse et pour les observateurs
c'est davantage pour mieux contrôler
l'islam du royaume que par véritable
esprit d'ouverture sur la scène
internationale l'image de l'arabie
saoudite demeure écornée par ses
multiples condamnations à la peine
capitale
et bien sûr par le meurtre barbare du
journaliste jamal rachedi qui selon
washington a nécessité l'accord du
prince héritier et dégâts causés par la
coalition au yémen menée par l'arabie
saoudite ajoute une ombre supplémentaire
au tableau tous ces avatars témoigne du
fait que le prince tient le royaume
d'une main de fer et quelques réformes
ne change rien au fond alors dans le
monde qui a exigé la libération de reiss
badaoui auprès de ce prince réformateur
opportuniste qui a osé s'opposer à ce
prêcheur de la libéralisation qui
enferme les militants des droits de
l'homme et de la femme répriment la
liberté d'expression mais qui signe de
juteux contrats
en 2018 le sénat américain a exigé la
libération de reiss badaoui de sa soeur
sans aucun résultat
l'arrivée de joe biden moins conciliant
que donald trump avec le prince pourrait
changer la donne
en effet le nouveau président affirme
avoir quelques exigences et vise le
prince dans le dossier rachedi
j'ai discuté jeudi avec le roi salman et
non avec le prince héritier
je lui ai clairement indiqué que les
règles avaient changé nous annoncerons
des changements importants aujourd'hui
et lundi nous les tiendrons pour
responsable des violations des droits de
l'homme au canada la mobilisation est
faible
pourtant la femme d'euralis badaoui ntaf
haïdar y vit depuis 2013 après avoir
obtenu l'asile avec ses trois enfants
elle s'y bat au quotidien
elle demande que la citoyenneté
canadienne soit accordée aux blogueurs
comme il sera interdit de sortie de
territoire pendant dix ans après sa
sortie de prison
cela pourrait l'aider à retrouver sa
famille mais pour le moment les
autorités canadiennes n'ont pas donné
suite
ce qui indigne les intellectuels du pays
et les sénateurs qui ont voté une motion
en ce sens et en france entendez-vous le
silence c'est normal ça ne fait pas de
bruit et pourtant la femme du blogueur a
interpellé emmanuel macron entre les
soutiens de façade occidentaux aux
opposants saoudien l'indifférence et les
réformes en trompe l'oeil du prince
le chemin va être long